[ __ ] ray fire how did you meet your
wife doing Sam yeah we met we met when
we were you know basically open my kurz
oh but we were friends cuz she had a
boyfriend
Asian you said that with why would you
say like that just no no but you put
pulls both hands toward me like a nice
thing I did it like disappointed Chinese
oh baby our good husband a good husband
yeah they were together for five years I
was friends with her we would do shows
like like part of the crew you know like
what would you give her [ __ ] eyes for
five years no no we were totally I was
always thought she was attractive but
you're like she's you know she's taken
and then I got the call like what am I
one of my spies was like yeah they broke
up and I was like I must swing in there
see what's up how long after they broke
up did you it was like a few months yeah
that's a long relationship was there
flirtation in there though before a
little bit I mean no I don't feel like
no there was never like anything like it
was like a respectful thing you know
like I was always I treated her like
with respect and just like another
economic really really yeah I really did
but he did somebody done say like she's
cute
yeah of course I thought she was cute
but I mean I was like if someone's like
that person lives with somebody you know
like yeah yeah yeah yeah I didn't even
consider it man Wow and then so it just
hit it off right away yeah we had a
couple of you know some funny I try to
have tried to tell a thing when I asked
her out the first time I called her and
I was like I was at work I was working
in post-production and I was making
small talk I was like so like you wanna
you know like get together maybe
Saturday she was like sure I was like
you want to go on a hike I was like a
very la ya know and then I just go
alright hung up I was like all right
later like I didn't get an although up
thing you didn't have a follow-up record
right like you don't wanna go hiking
dinner didn't like come to mind yeah I'm
kind of slow Rob I was like you were
shocked it will you embarrass begins are
through your hike [ __ ] well I didn't
even realize you saw through my hike
[ __ ] I just was like she doesn't want to
do something oh oh so then when I called
her the next time to go out I love that
you called her yeah it's really sweet
and this is like I call her the next
time and I'm like are my hike thing like
fails and she's like hey I know this bar
you can still smoke it do you want to go
there and I was like okay this is why
she doesn't want to go on a yeah so then
yeah then we just went on you know dates
and it just continued but it's amazing
but you guys are four years but not me
you know what guys just say something
yeah her yeah she's strong dude
oh yes oh she's amazing Beast
yeah she's great me yeah she's great
it's so it you rarely see two comics
that are super good she's I always know
a guy that's really good and his
girlfriend open-mike err yeah sure
right I never see two beasts you know
it's incredible well the thing I'm so
happy about now that her special came
out on Netflix and everything yeah she's
selling tickets so I'm like go out there
bring the money
[Music]
[Music]